atypique mais surtout chaotique ce 23
mars c'est une audience peu commune qui
s'est tenue au tribunal de toulouse
après huit heures de procès trois
recours en nullité de question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité le
tribunal n'a finalement pas tranché et a
re mis en délibéré au 4 mai prochain son
jugement concernant les 16 prévenus des
militants pour les droits des personnes
handicapées
tout d'abord revenons sur les faits en
2018 l'association handi sociale a
organisé deux actions une première
action gare matabiau à toulouse où les
militants se sont installés sur les
rails et ont bloqué une heure durant un
tgv
une deuxième action qui s'est tenue à
l'aéroport de toulouse les militants
sont parvenus à rentrer sur le tarmac et
donc à perturber le trafic
leur objectif dénoncer le manque
d'accessibilité aussi bien de l'aéroport
que de la gare je pense qu'elle la
illustrait pleinement à quel point caen
demain les robots remplaceront les juges
à quel point il n'y aura pas de
différence
revenons à ravenhill devant la justice
pour répondre de nos actes parce qu'en
fait nous est on les trouve légitime et
et si on est un peu passé ça peut pas se
justifier de deux c'est quand même grave
en fait des non sans de tels moyens
d'action la sncf
airbus air france mais aussi l'aéroport
de toulouse s'était constitué partie
civile
mais comme le souhaitait les avocats de
la défense aujourd'hui c'est davantage
le procès de l'accessibilité qu'autre
chose qui s'est tenue et même au delà de
la difficulté pour les personnes en
situation d'handicap de faire face à la
justice dans des conditions similaires
aux personnes valides
c'est la preuve que la justice n'a pas
su être allé pour aller coûte des
personnes en situation de handicap
les locaux n'étaient pas adaptés
l'audience n'était pas adapté l'écoutent
n'était pas très attentive
certains des prévenus ont du mal à
s'exprimer ils n'ont pas été en mesure
de le faire avec un interprète notamment
et donc il ya un goût amer qui raisin la
bouche même si on est allé jusqu'au bout
des choses
même si les différents avocats ont
plaidé notamment la relaxe la relaxe
pour des raisons politiques puisque
décision d'envahir le tarmac où la gare
a été causé pour faire comprendre la
situation des personnes en situation de
handicap
ils sont maltraités par la société par
la loi et par les gouvernements avant 2h
à la fin d'une journée d'une journée
d'audience éprouvante
les quelques policiers présents se sont
retrouvés avec une dizaine de personnes
en situation de handicap qui ne pouvait
tout simplement pas rentrer chez elle
c'est alors le président même du
tribunal qui a été contraint d'organiser
leur retour en contactant directement
tisséo qui est l'entreprise qui gère les
transports en commun de la ville
un épilogue qui illustre parfaitement le
combat que mènent ses militants